[Musique]
mesurer le degré de satisfaction des
salariés vis-à-vis de son environnement
de travail
c'est audi aussi identifier les besoins
et les attentes des salariés et donc
accroître l'actrice l'attractivité de
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
il ya un 1441 répond dans un territoire
qui est plébiscité par les salariés
notamment par les jeunes cadres qui le
note de 14 et demi sur 20 on s'aperçoit
que c'est un que saint quentin en
yvelines est un territoire à vivre
puisque 15% des salariés souhaiterait
déménager sur une des douze communes de
l'agglomération de saint quentin que 80%
fréquentent les équipements sportifs
culturels et commerces 85% 75% sont un
temps de trajet inférieur à une heure ce
qui satisfait 70% d'entre eux les
principales attentes c'est plutôt au
niveau de la restauration avoir une
offre un petit peu plus variés notamment
sur les circuits courts sur
l'agriculture biologique et avoir une
meilleure connaissance de manière
générale sur tout ce qui se passe sur le
territoire de saint quentin